when Orlando maka young wakes up he is
steps from the United States
he does his washing in the Rio Grande
River which separates Matamoros Mexico
where he stands now in the US on the
other side he can't cross a scar marks
the place where he says a loan shark in
Panama stole his kidney that's why he
fled about 45,000 asylum seekers are
currently waiting in Mexico for their
turn to see an American immigration
judge these border camps in Mexico are
the result of the Trump administration's
policy to deal with the backlog of three
hundred and thirty thousand Asylum cases
awaiting hearings when finally mega
Young's turn comes up to present himself
in US Court it won't be in a court at
all the Trump administration began
hosting video conference court sessions
in those white tents just on the US side
of the border an immigration judge calls
in from hundreds of kilometers away and
the asylum seeker is quickly rush right
back here to Mexico once the hearing is
completed and unlike a traditional court
session that is open to the public these
are done in secrecy migrant advocates
say the lack of transparency is a
problem but they're still more worried
about the likely outcome of the hearings
the supreme court ruled this month the
government can automatically deny asylum
to a person who crossed another country
before reaching the u.s. that covers
everybody in this camp it appends
decades of asylum law and it's just it
almost a little shell-shocked
individuals coming from across the world
fleeing global strife may not be able to
seek the protections they desperately
need under the new policy Mogollon has
no chance of winning asylum in the
United States alone US I don't have
words to describe the harm this
situation is doing to all the people in
the camp most people here have not
grasped the new reality that their
asylum
cesare now doomed from the start but
they're already here they say so they'll
try Heidi Joe Castro al Jazeera
Matamoros Mexico